[Musique]
il ya plusieurs arguments il ya des
arguments scientifiques
l'immense majorité des contaminations on
ne sait pas où elles se produisent très
probablement à l'intérieur mais nous
savons qu'il y a une part des
contaminations qui ont lieu à
l'extérieur
un deuxième élément scientifique comme
c'est qu'il ya plusieurs articles qui
montre la réduction de l'usagé du masque
à l'extérieur est associée à une
augmentation de la demande au cas ça
c'est beaucoup plus facile à identifier
quand il ya des gros pic épidémique
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
démontrer qu'en maintenant lorsque
l'épidémie est en phase décroissante et
il ya un troisième élément scientifique
également c'est que les nouveaux
variants sont beaucoup plus contaminant
faut commencer par dire qu'on ne doit
pas s'en séparer en intérieur il a quand
même quelques études qui ont été faites
et notamment celle de l'institut pasteur
qui s'appelle comme corps 42% des
contaminations se font à l'intérieur du
domicile donc en intérieur et que pour
toutes les contaminations hors domicile
et on suppose temps qui reste
c'était ça se répartissent de la manière
suivante 95% était en intérieur et 5% en
extérieur donc en réalité on n'est même
pas sur un 10 15% des contaminations qui
se ferait en extérieur mais probablement
plus sur quelque chose de l'ordre de 1
2%
la vraie question c'est est-ce que je
pousse ses masques en extérieur ont un
intérêt dans la mesure où il faut le
dire
cette mesure est très bien respectée je
pense qu'il serait plus judicieux de
dire ok on enlève les masques en
extérieur en revanche on va organiser
dans les lieux où il ya des fortes
densités même en extérieur
typiquement par exemple les marchés la
distribution de masques gratuits port
neuf et qui effectivement du coup serait
efficace et on éduque de la population à
porter des masques quand c'est une forte
densité de population
tant que nous aurons la menace qu vide
nous devrons continuer à utiliser le
masque les données qui ont été
présentées elles sont parfaitement réel
mais entre temps nous savons les
nouveaux variants sont plus
transmissible et nous savons que le
virus ne passe pas uniquement par les
postillons mais passe aussi par des
aérosols donc une contamination plus
aisé aujourd'hui la règle doit être le
port du masque est que nous sommes à
l'extérieur et il pourrait y avoir des
zones de tolérance comme les terrasses
il pourrait y avoir une zone de
tolérance comme les plages ou les
secteurs où la population est donc une
activité sportive
à côté de ça le reste du temps il faut
porter le masque et il y à un dernier
élément aussi qui est essentiel c'est
que lorsque on va décider de porter ou
pas le masque ça ne peut pas être une
décision politique me sociologique
il va falloir que ce soit l'académie de
médecine
le collège des enseignants de maladies
infectieuses le collège des experts ont
mis chaîne qui reprendront les vingt
mille articles ont été écrits sur le
sujet et qu'ils nous diront il faut il
faut pas porter cette année là nous
n'avons pas eu des rires
cette année là nous n'avons pas eu de
bronchiolite part pas du tout devant
curie taux quasiment pas et pas du tout
de grip ou quasiment pas ça montre bien
que le masque
s'il ya quelque chose que nous avons de
cette pandémie
c'est que respecter les autres et porter
le masque est essentiel pour les
protéger le fait qu'on ait le moindre
bribe le fait qu'on ait de nombreuses
polices et ses potentiels dans la masse
comme ça peut être potentiellement aussi
beaucoup plus de laval à demain ça peut
être potentiellement il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont pu rentrer en ligne de
compte et ça peut l'être notamment être
les masses comme intérieure mais pas
forcément les masques en extérieur je
suis prêt
il faut être il faut trouver une
justement il y as au-delà de la question
scientifique et médicale qui est certes
là qui est certes réel de toute façon
cette décision à la fin elle est
politique elle est politique au moment
où les masques ce n'était pas utile
selon le ministère de la santé il ya
encore un an
puis elle est de nouveau politique en
ces masques sont rendus obligatoires en
intérieur avançant sida on n'a pas une
vérité médical qui établit qui
permettrait de prendre une décision
politique définitive je pense que il ya
une vérité médicale qui reste encore à
définir pour le masque en extérieur
j'entends je répète parce que en
intérieur c'est pas du tout la même le
même schéma c'est pas du tout le même
raisonnement et c'est pas du tout les
mêmes données on ne pense pas que ce
soit en entendant de l'imposer encore
plus si en dix ans et ça maintenant la
nouvelle norme qu'on arrivera à faire
adhérer la population
nous ne pouvons pas prendre le risque de
baisser les bras
tant qu'il y aura un seul pays où il ya
encore du virus qui circule et nous
sommes loin d'avoir vacciné tous les
pays au monde et tous les endroits où le
virus circule de façon importante
quand vous dites le port du masque est
obligatoire en extérieur pour tout le
monde sauf dans les terrasses sauf à la
plage sauf sauf sauf sur s'offre enfin
que c'est plus intelligible alors que si
vous dites le port du masque n'est pas
obligatoire mais il est fortement
conseillé dans une zone à forte densité
et que les pouvoirs publics organisent
cette distribution
là vous avez une chance que ce soit
respectée